what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and things are going down right now in
the Multiverse in the Marvel Cinematic
Multiverse right now it looks like
ultimately the entire Multiverse is
going to start collapsing which is going
to bring us right into Avengers Secret
Wars and apparently this is going to be
a pretty big plot point for the ending
of the Fantastic 4 Reboot film that is
coming to the MCU hopefully pretty soon
fingers crossed so today we'll talk
about a new report that has been going
around that talks about how the
Fantastic 4 is going to end and then
goes into Secret Wars it does line up
with some other reports that we have
heard recently so this could actually be
what is going to happen in the Fantastic
4 film and yes if you were wondering it
does involve Galactus and hopefully a
non-cloud form Galactus and yes it does
look like this film is going to take
place in Another Universe which we've
been talking about for a while so let's
dive into to it and if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to stay up
to date on the Fantastic 4 and MCU and
if you subscribe and leave a comment you
are automatically entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items winner gets to pick one
item and we pick one winner at the end
of each month so this report today is
coming from somebody who leaks some
stuff about secret Invasion that ended
up being accurate same thing goes for
some leaks about Daredevil born again
now that Daredevil born again is
essentially cancelled the version that
they had at least and is now being
Rewritten and reworked a lot of what was
going to happen during the first season
has been coming out and one of those
things is that foggy was going to be
dead in Daredevil born again he was
going to be killed off in episode one
that has now come to light and been
proven true will that happen in the
rewrite for Daredevil born again we're
unsure but the point is that report was
right so it's coming from user / deborn
one and here's the report fantastic 4's
last draft had them in the 60s in
Another Universe now this is what we've
heard so far so this is in line with
everything that we've heard many
insiders have reported about this so
it's probably true since a lot of people
are hearing the same thing and I have a
theory on how I think it's all going to
work out in the end after Secret Wars
but the report continues to state where
they are the only Heroes and huge Stars
speaking of the universe that they are
in so they're going to be the only
heroes in this universe it's essentially
going to be like one of the old
fantastic ftic four films that we saw
there are no other heroes in those
universes it's just the Fantastic Four
and they're famous because they are
again the only superheroes so of course
all the spotlight is going to be on them
plus something I have always loved about
the Fantastic 4 is that they do not hide
who they are their identities are known
to everyone so obviously they're going
to be pretty famous in this other
Universe the report continues and States
they have to save their world from
galatis and his Heralds but they lose
and here's where gets juicy and the TVA
save them and take them to the new
universe now this is very very
interesting and I do really like the
idea of them losing to galatis and also
being taken to a new universe that way
when they get to a new universe and we
move forward in that new universe a
whole bunch of new stories can happen
because they are in a different Universe
now this lines up really well with
everything that we've heard about
Deadpool 3 what we've heard from
insiders is that in Deadpool 3 the
Multiverse is going to start to collapse
and a lot of incursions are going to
start to happen so the TVA is going to
start to take certain heroes from
universes that are collapsing and dying
and they're going to take them and put
them all in one Universe on one world
kind of like a spin on Avengers Secret
Wars battle world and even though they
are saving a bunch of Heroes I'm sure
they'll actually try to save some
powerful villains as well because from
what we believe the TVA is going to save
certain people so they can help fight
King and all of the king variants so
once all of these Heroes and I believe
villains are going to be in one place
I'm sure they're going to fight I'm sure
it still will be a type of battle world
we can assume that they're not all going
to get along especially if you have
people like Victor Von Doom going up
against Reed Richards going up against
Tony Stark going up against Doctor
Strange a lot of conflicting big
personalities there and what I basically
imagine is kind of like how the first
Avengers film was they all fought a lot
in the beginning and almost wanted to
physically fight each other Captain
America and Tony Stark but eventually
come together in the end I think that's
what's going to happen in Deadpool 3 and
Secret Wars however I think some actual
fighting is really going to go down
especially because we know that not
everyone is going to survive the events
of Deadpool 3 but apparently the end of
the Fantastic 4 is going to show us the
Fantastic 4 losing to Galactus and some
of his Heralds maybe the Silver Surfer
fingers crossed and then the TVA is
going to take them to this battle World
type of place and from there I'm sure
all of the heroes are going to come
together and say hey we got to defeat
Kang and his variant we got to get rid
of the Council of kangs and that will be
secret Wars now what happens to the
Fantastic 4 after Secret Wars as well as
the other Heroes I have a theory we'll
talk about that in just a bit but first
big thank you to fume for sponsoring
this video fume is a GameChanger for a
lot of people in turning bad habits into
good habits a lot of people struggle
with these bad habits but fume looks at
these in a different way not everything
in the habit
is wrong so instead of a drastic
uncomfortable change why not just remove
the bad from your habit and that's
exactly what fume does they're
Innovative and they're award-winning and
they're a flavored air device that's all
it is it's flavored air so it has none
of the bad things and the bad habit in
it instead of vapor it uses flavored Air
instead of electronics fume is
completely natural and instead of
harmful chemicals fume uses delicious
flavors I had actually heard really
great things about fume from my friends
who were struggling with some bad habits
they actually raved about it and how it
helped them which is why I agreed to
partner with them and they sent me some
samples and they honestly are super
refreshing and taste very flavorful and
good and it comes in beautiful real wood
and it's honestly really fun to just sit
there and kind of fidget with if you're
someone who likes to fidget like I do
and I know stopping is something we all
put off because it's hard but with fume
it's easy and they have served over
150,000 customers and have thousands of
success stories and that could be you if
you pick up a journey pack today head
over to trif nume.com and use code
Cosmic to save 10% off when you get the
journey pack today that's TR
f.com and use code Cosmic to save an
additional 10% off your order today so I
think at this point in time a lot of
people know that a lot of insiders have
reported that Marvel Studios is planning
to do a soft reboot at the end of
Avengers secret War slthe beginning of
phase 7 or possibly a phase one again
depending on how they decide to do that
and the fact that a lot of people are
reporting about the Fantastic 4 coming
from Another Universe into one Universe
where a lot of other people are going to
exist whether that be our main Earth 616
universe or Universe where the TVA has
collected everybody it seems like a lot
of different heroes and villains are
going to wind up in one Universe well
going forward I think that is probably
how the MCU is going to proceed in that
one universe and I think this might be
sort of a Best of Both Worlds situation
because if you do a hard reboot then
everything that happened in the infinity
Saga did not happen and that would be
kind of a slap in the face to us fans
and the actors who play the characters
and of course the characters themselves
but keeping characters and people in one
universe who remember those old events
that way they can live on well that
makes it to where that all still did
happen but we are in a brand new
universe now and this could explain how
the Fantastic 4 stay in the main
Universe since they're not going to be
in the main Universe at first because it
wouldn't be part of Marvel studios's
plans to have the Fantastic 4 Come From
Another Universe and then go back to
that universe but proceed with
storytelling of the Fantastic 4 in that
Universe because that would be
completely separate from everything else
that is going on so the logical
explanation to how they're going to move
forward is the Fantastic 4 leave their
universe and stay in our universe moving
forward in the MCU as of right now it's
very clear that in the earth 616
Universe there's not a famous superhero
group called The Fantastic 4 out there
anywhere because we would have heard
about them the only mention of the
Fantastic 4 that we kind of got was in
Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness which also might have been a
reference to the Fantastic 4 actually
taking place back in time in the 60s
when Reed Richards is introduced in
Multiverse of Madness doctor strain says
the Fantastic Four didn't you guys chart
in the 6s implying that they were
actually a musical group which could
very well be the case in our universe
they might might not be the superheroes
that we know to be the Fantastic 4 in
the earth 616 universe but in a
different reality could be a band
whereas in this other Universe where the
movie is said to take place in they are
the superhero group that is famous so
needless to say the Fantastic 4 if they
somehow exist in our universe are very
different but it sounds like the
Multiverse a lot of these different
universes that create the Multiverse are
going to be jammed into one universe and
moving forward that will be our new MCU
I'm sure we'll talk about this more but
right away go ahead and let us know your
thoughts about this in the comments down
below do you like this idea for the
Fantastic 4 being in Another Universe
and then coming into ours being saved at
the End by the TVA or would you rather
It Go differently let us know your
thoughts in the comments don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you can
stay up to date on the Fantastic 4 in
the MCU you can find us on Instagram and
Twitter as well and as always thank you
all so much for watching woof
woof